if you're looking to get up and close
and personal with Bill and Hillary
Clinton you're in luck
the Clintons announcing today they're
going on a North American tour they'll
visit four cities the rest of this year
and nine more in 2019 the event is
dubbed quote an evening with President
Bill Clinton and former Secretary of
State Hillary Rodham Clinton Dana you
buying a ticket I gotta go to bed early
that night and every night um I think
that these will sell out people are
gonna want to see them remember she did
win the popular vote and he's still
popular amongst people but it's if you
go out if you leave your bubble and you
go out to the country and you want to
I'm all for it it's a great way for them
to be out and about up together it's fun
thing to do as a couple if Peter and I
will be coming to a city near you
with the dog big seller the dog you know
but the thing is Jesse I think Clinton
Bill Clinton has not been having a good
time I mean you even see ads run by
Democrats Auntie Cavanaugh ads and they
got Clinton and them so I'm just
wondering true this is quite a moment
yeah it's a me-too boomerang for a good
old bill and Hillary's kind of branded
as a loser remember she lost big time
and a lot of Democrats are kind of angry
at her for whipping so hard and letting
Trump be President she was a terrible
candidate but if you look at the
Clintons over here and then the Obamas
over here you have two former presidents
and first ladies who are extremely
political active still and extremely
partisan they're not these elder
statesmen they're both there in the
trenches throwing hand grenades and it
does suck up a lot of oxygen for
presidential candidates and it makes the
Democratic Party look like the party of
the past where the Democratic Party
traditionally has been branded as the
party of the future so it's not a good
look for them right now and by the way
big and there's a Broadway play coming
next year about the Clinton oh goodie
goodie goodie put on my calendar so I
think that Bill and Hillary's wedding
anniversary
is this Thursday they will have been
married 43 years and I think that she
should go on the road and at one of
these events let him have it lose her
mind and go after him for everything
that he did take it for that
you know what that would be they should
pay per view that that would be at 5 or
6 million paper bigger than the burger
to go after him and let him how I put up
with all of this all that philandering
all those years you couldn't even get me
in the White House and I lost a Batman
please that would be awesome
Batman what's this language David I
haven't checked but I think the Clinton
tour is not going to Wisconsin the you
know about this she's thinking as she's
doing the tour this will pay for the
renovation in the second house and he's
thinking how am I gonna score groupies
with her around how much money do they
really need he's gonna he's he's only
going to the states where there's a
Hooters and a local but heavily
frequented rest stop by the way so
Michelle Obama is also going out and her
ticket prices are even higher than the
Hillary Clinton ticket price the most
popular people in America and you know
much bigger venues I think that she's in
some like fifteen thousand seat not
bigger than trophy news huge crowds
begging you you gotta get in tune with
this crowd here this is this is from
playing here